oh no one would know better than hermit
Dylan herself chair one of the
Republican National Lawyers Association
who joins us now hermit thanks so much
for coming on is it true that you plan
to run for RNC chair
well Tucker I'm going to announce
tonight that actually I am going to run
for RNC chair and the reason is that you
know to play off of a famous catchphrase
Republicans are tired of losing and I
think that we really need to radically
reshape our leadership in order to win
and we can't keep running elections like
we did in the 90s and the 2000s and we
really have to modernize to compete with
the Democrats dollar for dollar and the
ways they fundraise the way they deliver
their ballots to the ballot boxes our
messaging needs to be fresh and positive
and not just reactive to news cycles and
what the Democrats are doing and I think
that the party needs to realize that the
party has become a populist party the
base of the party demands populist
messages that speak to them and not
Chamber of Commerce messages not neocon
messages not warmonger messages and I'm
afraid that the base of our party is not
getting what it needs from our
leadership and so after three successive
rounds of really disappointing results
Tucker I'm a member of the RNC and no
other member is stepping up to challenge
leadership and our current leadership
has never been challenged for the chair
job and I think that challenge and
competition is very good and so I'm
hoping to gain the support of Grassroots
Americans who do not like the direction
of the party and its leadership they
need to contact the 168 members of the
RNC in their states and territories and
tell them that they too want change and
I think that change is popular among the
base I hear from thousands of Americans
on a weekly basis about that they want
to see us fighting Tucker you know as
well as anybody else that I'm a fighter
yes you are every waking hour of the day
and that's what we need right now and so
that's me I'm offering to take a giant
you know step back from my law firm and
my non-profit to do this it's a big
sacrifice but I think it's important for
our country that I love so much as a
first generation immigrant I love it I
love it I can vouch for your toughness
it's absolutely real and much needed
godspeed hear me telling rooting for you
thank you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight